there are many reasons to suspect that
one of the dominant problems in the
world today is an excess of anger we
hear so much about the very shouty in
their antics that tantrums their lack of
reason their unwillingness to compromise
but it may be rather more realistic
albeit a bit odd sounding to insist on
the very opposite that whatever the
impression generated by a publicly vocal
angry cohort the far more common yet
invisible problem is a contrary tendency
a widespread inability to get angry a
failure to know how rightly and
effectively to mount a complaint an
inarticulate swallowing of frustration
and the bitterness subterranean acting
out and low-level depression that can
follow from not allowing any of our
rightful sorrows to find expression for
every one person who shouts too loudly
there are at least twenty who have
unfairly lost their voice we're not
talking here in praise of delirious rage
the sort that injures innocents and
leads nowhere the point isn't to
rehabilitate barbarism it's to make a
case for an occasional capacity to speak
up in order to correct a reason sense
that something isn't right and that
those around us need to take our
perspective onboard we are as a rule
hopeless at being angry from the very
nicest of motives in part from a belief
in the complexity of situations and the
minds of other people which undercuts
enthusiasm for anything that might smack
of self-righteousness or pride we tell
ourselves in relationships or at work
that other people must have their good
reasons for behaving as they do there
must be essentially kind and good and
that it would be an insult to their
efforts to raise our hand about a
problem that probably we don't even
entirely understand we tend to import
this kind of modesty from childhood it's
actually a privilege to allow
child to manifest their frustration and
not all parents are on for it some are
very keen to keen on having a good child
they let their child know from the very
first that being naughty isn't funny and
that this isn't a family where children
are going to be allowed to run rings
around the adults so difficult moods and
Tantrums complaints and rage are not
going to be part of the story this
doesn't show short-term compliance but
paradoxically good behavior is usually a
precursor of bad feelings and in
extremes mental unwellness in adulthood
feeling loved enough that one can dare
to tell parents to sod off and
occasionally fling something soft across
the room belongs to health truly mature
parents have a few rules but they also
allow their children sometimes to break
them otherwise there can be a species of
inner deadness that comes from having
had to be too good too soon and to
resign ones point of view without a
flicker of self defense in relationships
this might mean a tendency to get taken
royally for a ride for many years not in
terms of outright abuse though that -
but the kind of low-level humiliation
and taken-for-granted Ness which seems
the lot of people who can't make a fuss
at work an unwavering concern for
politeness empathy and gentleness may
end up providing the perfect
preconditions for being walked all over
so we should at times relearn the
neglected art of politely being a pain
the danger of those who've never shanked
it is that they might in compensation
end up screaming that isn't the point
either the goal is to learn to protest
in a firm but self-possessed way
something like this excuse me but you
are ruining what's left of my life I'm
so sorry but your cauterizing my chances
of happiness I beg your pardon but this
is enough we have the speeches written
in our heads already there is likely to
be a spouse a parent a colleague or a
child who hasn't heard enough from us
for far too long
and who it would be of incalculable
benefit to our heart rate and our
emotional and physical Constitution to
have a word with timid people always
imagine that anger might destroy
everything good are they overlooked
probably because their childhoods
encouraged them to do so that anger can
also be a kind of fertilizer from which
something a lot less bitter and a lot
more alive can eventually emerge
our arguments book is a guide to
arguments in love it teaches us why they
might occur what their symptoms are how
we could learn some wiser ways of
communicating and how we would ideally
patch up after a fight